hi my name is any park and I'm the
director of visual development at marvel
studios me and a group of artists we
have the fun job of designing the
characters that you see in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe we thought it would
be a fun opportunity to give you a
little bit behind-the-scenes glimpse
into how we sketch how we design a
character these heroes and villains and
in this case I'm going to be drawing
someone that's very near and dear to my
heart
Natasha Romanov aka Black Widow so check
out this video hopefully afterwards you
get a little bit something out of it
we're gonna make this drawing that I do
available for download so feel free to
color it to draw over it to trace it the
whole point is to learn and to have fun
so with that said let's get drawing okay
let's get started
normally for my work I use Photoshop
Adobe Photoshop and I work digitally
because in my job as a concept artist
I'm always making changes to my drawings
to my designs based on the directors or
the producers or sometimes the actors so
I need to be able to make changes very
easily so drawing digitally is just the
easiest way to make changes you can draw
traditionally using paper and a pen and
paper but it's always harder to like you
know you have ten you have to erase all
the time or do a new drawing so I
typically will do all my concept
illustrations and my drawings in
Photoshop for my job at Marvel Studios
so as you can see this is the Photoshop
layout I'll usually start off you know
about eight and a half eight and a half
by eleven pretty much or eight by eleven
inches 300 dpi and I'll start sketching
just using you know a circle brush that
squashed you can see in the lower right
corner and about 25% gray and then I'll
start sketching I'm going to start
roughing out whatever I'm trying to draw
in this case I'm trying to draw a black
widow
and I'm thinking of her in a you know
fairly not to action e of a pose but I
want her to look like maybe she's like
walking forward or she's walking down a
corridor and she's seeking out
taskmaster
as you'll see in the upcoming Black
Widow film hopefully soon so that's my
thinking and doing this initial sketch
so I'm just trying to rough out you know
proportions size of the head the body
the pose they have to flow of the hair
so a lot of times what you'll see me
what you should what you're seeing we do
right now is just you know doing
adjustments like I can take a part of
the head and just shrink it cuz I felt
like it was a little too big and then I
can make it some adjustments you can
also do this in procreate in if you have
an iPad as well so working digitally has
these advantages where I can make these
adjustments and make something larger or
smaller on the fly versus if I drew it
on paper which is totally fine I used to
draw comics for about 10 years so I have
to erase and redraw it so either way it
works but I'm just taking advantage of
the tools that I have in in Photoshop so
you know I can make some adjustments I
felt like the belt was a little too high
and I added a little bit of curvature so
what you're seeing is me just constantly
making adjustments to the original
sketch that I did I feel like I have a
good base to work off of now I'm just
trying to refine you know size of the
foot the details going up and down
throughout the figure to figure out and
then I can zoom in and start doing I
don't want to go detail at this point
you know I'm still trying to just get
the overall feel I'm not thinking about
lines I'm thinking more about just
overall drawing you know
so I moved their head a little bit
forwards I felt like that would make it
a little bit more interesting than just
you know straight up and down so going a
little bit forward on the body makes her
a little bit more ready for whatever's
coming around the corner I lowered the
opacity and I added a new layer so that
I can draw on top of the old drawing
that I just had that I just did and at
this point I'm adding a little bit of
details on the costume now that I have
the general figure kind of blocked in
and I'm trying to figure out like okay
now I can start drawing in the costume
but although all this while I'm not
thinking about pretty lines I'm not
thinking about okay I need to get all
these lines to look beautiful I am
merely just really going as fast as I
can to just kind of rough in all the
details and then from you know later on
you can you know start refining more and
more and start getting more and more
depressed area going to be doing that in
this tutorial because it's not about
that it's more about just my thinking
when it comes to drawing how I go about
going from a blank page start laying in
details and figuring out the gesture the
character the pose the costume and all
that all that kind of stuff so for this
tutorial I am drawing one of black
widows costumes that you're going to be
seeing eventually in the theaters from
the Black Widow film so this is
wonderful costumes because she has a
couple and it's it's always fun to draw
because this is a character that I've
been I had the honour of designing ever
since Avengers way back and when I was
working on in those 2010 the family came
out in 2012 but you know I designed all
of Natasha Romanovs
costumes and all her film appearances
since the Avengers
and it's really been a pleasure because
it's just character you know played by
Scarlett Johansson it it's just really
interesting it's always a character that
I've always want you know I think the
audience and myself included always
wanted to know more about you know we
get hints of our past we get hints you
know she talks about a red ledger and
just there's there's so many things in a
way that Scarlett Johansson portrays or
has just always been such an interesting
character and of course if you've seen
infinity warren in game you see kind of
the culmination of her journey and it's
such a heroic gesture that she made I
don't want to spell it out for those 10
people who have on this earth who
haven't watched endgame but there'll be
spoilers but you know for those of you
who have watched it know you know what a
heroic act she made in that film and she
is the ultimate hero you know that's
that's her story and of course we're
gonna be diving way deeper into her
story her backstory who Roman
Natasha is as a person as a hero from
her present to her past and she's just a
really interesting Avengers a really
interesting person really interesting
character so to be able to design her
costumes throughout all these years from
Avengers to her next appearance in how
was it
Captain America Civil War and I think
I'm right I'm sorry
Captain America Winter Soldier is what I
meant to say and then after that was
Avengers age of Ultron then then Captain
America Civil War Avengers infinity war
and Avengers end game and then in the
upcoming solo film Black Widow I think I
named all of her film appearances
so to be able to revisit or look again
for this film you know what's great and
you know I'd love to talk about my
thinking behind this costume maybe
briefly I can't go too into depth
because I don't want to spoil anything
for the film but you know her costumes
I've always been very utilitarian it's
it's it's all about practicality it's
all about efficiency and getting the job
done she's a spy she's she's adaptable
in any situation she's intelligent brave
and sneaky and she's got all the moves
so you know she's she's got that that
looked from the comic or just very sleek
it's always pretty much black that's why
it was fun in this film to be able to
tackle a suit that was the opposite
which is white so you know she can
shouldn't that doesn't she can't always
hide and be stealthy in black because
there are certain situations where you
know she might have to blend in with a
white environment so yeah
I'm drawing in all the details from her
black widow film costume her latest one
this one has a lot of gray in it
there's always black but this one I
probably have more light gray or medium
grade and any of her past films and that
was you know a nod to one of her designs
in the Marvel comics back in the 80s so
you know I've always liked that look
with a big color great costume and the
other thing that I really wanted to
infuse into this costume that she's
never had but she's always had in the
comics was her gold gauntlets and her
gold belt
so those are two things that I was
really happy that the director and the
producers were were totally happy to you
know allow her to have gold so maybe in
the past if gold was just a little bit
too late
Michael this is not very stealthy it
kind of stands out but I think we found
a good a happy medium and doing gold but
it's you know not bling gold jewelry
gold it's more whether it's more toned
down so it looks pretty awesome in the
film so I was really happy with the way
it came out
so yeah I'm drawing all the elements and
the guns to the hands a gun in the hands
I as you noticed I drew last because the
guns hands are always like challenging
and I want to get them right so you know
like a lot of times I'll use reference
and in this case I'm not showing it here
but I took photos of my hands holding a
toy gun so that I can just kind of get
that right and I'm making some
adjustments in the foot because I felt
like it needs to she needs to look more
like she's walking forward rather than
you know flat-footed in the back foot so
that looks a little better what you know
she's on her toes and her back I felt
like her head was a little weird tilted
that way so I straightened it out I
darkened the entire drawing and again as
you can tell like I'm not thinking about
this whole drawing tutorials not about
how to do great amazing line work
because it's really rough as you can
still tell but you know it's got enough
detail that you know you can tell what's
going on and still interesting but it's
not you know like like a lot of times in
comics they're like really refine nice
pretty line drawings this I would have
to go another step and to make it really
pretty but you know that's not the point
of this it's more about how to draw it's
not so much how to ink or do pretty line
art and this one I felt like I need to
add a little bit of the tone so that's
why I added the darks for the blacks to
suggest the blacks and these Gray's for
the grays and then she has red hair
red colours is dark so that's why I felt
like it needed that to kind of have this
kind of completed and look and at this
point I felt like I want to do just a
little bit more detail and refinement on
the face so I zoomed in a little bit I
don't want to go too much and you know
I'm just gonna start cleaning up a
little bit I'm not destroying is not
about doing a drawing of Scarlett
Johansson because that's clearly not a
likeness but it's just more the essence
of the character black widow rather than
the actress cuz that would be a whole
nother tutorial in itself but at this
point I'm trying to just add a little
bit more detail interest refining a
little because I felt like it's just you
know the face is the focus of any figure
drawing that you do character so I just
wanted to make it a little nicer adding
little details a little bit of value
color I think that adds a lot and
refining just so that you know when you
see the drawing you know the rest of it
can be really rough and the face is
still gonna stay rough but adding a
little bit more detail I think it just
adds so much more so when you're doing
your drawings just keep that in mind you
know people we all tend to look at the
face whenever we look at a drawing if
it's of a character so you definitely
want the head and the face to really be
strong and the rest can be rougher it
doesn't have to be as detailed as the
rest and it it all kind of like holds
together and here I'm kind of just
chiseling out I felt like there was too
much training too much hair on top and
the sides so that's just refining and
it's you know I always I really love
just drawing faces painting faces in my
job as a concept designer I'm not really
drawing as much as I am painting so what
you're seeing me do here is not really
something that I I do I might
a job because I'll at this point I'll
start painting and adding colors and
using more brush strokes so you there
you can see the difference you know I
just went on and off but that layer to
show that before and after and so at
this point I feel pretty good I feel
pretty good about this drawing I think
it's you know again like I can spend
another hour refine even more adding
textures and all that stuff but you know
this is just to get an overall drawing
you're seeing me flip the canvas a lot
and basically that is just to see my
mistakes when you see something in a
different perspective that's when you
see one eye is lower than the other so I
definitely advise you guys to constantly
flip your canvas or you know hold it up
to a light or look it in a mirror I hope
this has helped because it's definitely
a fun one fun character for me to draw
and write there I headed Scarlett
Johansson's mole again isn't that I'm
not claiming that that's a great
likeness of Scarlett Johansson but you
know I hasn't if you if you were to see
this character or this drawing you know
most people would say oh that's black
widow they would know who it is they
might not necessarily say that Scarlett
Johansson but they'll notice Black Widow
so that's what I was trying to
accomplish and the last thing that I'll
do and that everyone out there should do
after they draw it they don't have to do
all the time but you know 2020 Andy Park
that's my signature and yeah there you
go if you want to see more of my
drawings and my paintings that stuff
that I do at marvel studios please check
out my social media at Andy Park art on
Instagram Twitter and YouTube well I
hope to see your drawings I would love
to see your take on Black Widow or any
other Marvel Studios hero or villain and
please tag me because I'd love to check
it out I try to make whatever comments
or critique that I can but keep drawing
out there
stay safe and I hope to see all your
awesome drawings
very soon take care